there's this never ending conversation that
basically just happens in talking points.
Everybody just says they're talking points
and [inaudible]
we never get anywhere and it has to do with
mass shootings and supposedly good guys with
guns. And the way it usually works is someone
will ultimately say after some shooting, the
reason that this shooting happened or was
as deadly as it was, is not too many guns
or too much access to guns. It's too few guns.
We need more good guys with guns so that they
can either prevent or more quickly stop these
mass shooting incidents. Now this of course
ignores that most shooting incidents are not
mass shooting incidents. They're individual
homicides and suicides. But putting that aside
for a second, someone will then inevitably
inevitably come back and say, well, where
were the good guys with guns? Because a lot
of these shootings are happening in places
where it is relatively easy to get a concealed
carry permit. For example, they didn't stop
the shooting and then the pro gun side will
come back and they'll say, well, it was a
gun free zone, which only prevents good guys
from having guns.
The bad guys are gonna ignore the rules and
bring the guns anyway, and then we never get
anywhere. So let's sort of try to step back
from the generalities of those talking points
for a second and talk specifically about Texas
and Ohio in these particular cases. And disclaimer,
this video is going to be demonetized by youtube.
As I told you yesterday, all week we've been
trying to have serious adult conversations
about crime and violence in society. Those
stories are all instantly demonetized by youtube.
This is probably our 12th demonetization this
week. So the reality about the good guy with
a gun is that he can rarely, if ever, stop
a mass shooting. This got traction after Sandy
Hook in 2012 the NRAS vice president, then
vice president, I don't know if he still is.
Wayne Lapierre said, the only way to stop
a bad guy with a gun is a good guy with a
gun.
And then people started talking about arming
teachers and guns in more places and it just
doesn't work. It's not even a myth. It's really
a delusion. The reality is the opposite of
the talking point. In a ton of cases, armed
so-called good guys with guns in public places
are likely to make mass shootings. Worse.
Experts agree. Okay. Stanford law professor
John Donahue says quote, unless you're very
well trained, this means like military level
training. You usually add more to the body
count. Then you subtract. You don't need to
think too imaginatively to understand why
this is. There's a bad guy with a gun, starts
shooting 30 to 60 seconds later, a good guy
with a gun. If he can even figure out what's
going on and who to shoot starts shooting
back another 30 to 60 seconds later. Like
in Ohio where police responded very quickly,
police show up, they see two people shooting
and now there are two guys with guns that
police have to assess who's good, who's bad.
Police required to fire more shots to take
down the bad guy. If they can even figure
out who that is, of which there are now possibly
two as [inaudible]. As far as police are concerned,
it's chaos. It leads to more injury, it leads
to more death. So then now let's look more
specifically at Texas and Ohio. In the last
few years, both states have expanded gun rights.
They've made it easier to concealed carry.
In Ohio 2017 you can then, uh, you, you were
then allowed to start bringing guns to day
care centers on private planes. Employees
are allowed to bring guns in Ohio to company
parking lots. For example, in Texas, 10 new
expansive gun laws that we discussed on the
bonus show this week are being added almost
as we speak of fewer than four weeks from
now. And meanwhile we see that armed civilians
responding to mass shooters in public places
to prevent shootings basically don't exist.
You'll hear some few anecdotal cases, but
even in cases where someone with a gun starts
shooting back, hypothetically, the shootings
typically last very little time, 30 60 seconds
of actual shooting. Sometimes you do get a
a few minutes. No one reacts the way they
think they would. Even police who are trained
often don't react as expected. And in a chaotic
live shooter scenario, the good guy with a
gun is simply another guy with a gun to police.
Joe Henry, the director of risk assessments
and a national trainer at the Alice Training
Institute says quote, it's a very difficult
thing to shoot in a room that's full of people
while someone is shooting at you. When police
show up, the shooting is underway or it's
over more shooters in these scenarios do not
help when even police don't react as training
would dictate. They should. What do you think
the average person is going to do?
The average person, even with gun safety training
and even some response training, we'll either
do nothing or they will panic and shoot the
wrong people or get themselves shot by police.
When police arrive, security guards, they're
not military, they're not police. We're talking
about guards in schools, armed guards in schools.
Can you imagine? And then think about scenarios
where it doesn't even make a difference. Look
at the Las Vegas shooting. Uh, what good were
good guys with guns to stop a guy in a hotel
room with high powered weapons? Oh, Hio itself.
Look at what happened in Ohio over the weekend,
near instantaneous response by trained police.
The entire thing lasted a minute. The guy
killed a ton of people and some people call
it the good guy with a gun myth. It's really
a fantasy or a delusion. As I said earlier,
the number one thing we can do to fix, uh,
the gun issue and gun deaths is fix our culture
so that fewer people see guns as the way to
solve a problem or prove a political point
or as an outlet for distress that they're
experiencing.
When they say, let's talk about mental health
as the cause. Well then fund it. You can't
say the issue is mental health and then do
nothing to increase access to mental health
treatment. And by the way, I mean this, I
don't even want to get into this, but if the
issue is mental health as some claim it to
be, you then need a system to block people
with certain conditions from having guns,
which many Republicans are against anyway.
And it also opens up a very, quite frankly
complex conversation about which diagnoses
preclude you from having a gun and that's
a whole other topic. Would the right be okay
with saying anyone diagnosed with um, uh,
adjustment disorder, which has sort of like
this catchall, a generic mental health diagnosis
that's often used merely to get insurance
coverage for mental health treatment. Does
that preclude you from having a gun?
Does anxiety per se preclude you from having
a gun? What about depression? Does anyone
on antidepressants get banned from having
guns? I mean the, the, the, it's a mental
health issue ignores number one that the people
claiming that don't really want to fund access
to mental health typically. And number two,
that what exactly would be the mechanism and
conditions that would preclude you from having
a gun, a conversation for a different day.